bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 lecture sur tv
fil 78 le journal de la rédaction voici
les principaux titres que nous allons
développer au cours des 26 prochaines
minutes
le porte parole du npa venus soutenir
les grévistes de la faim du syndicat sud
de l'entreprise psa à poissy
il évoque des régressions sociales et
harcèlement de monde nous resterons dans
le monde du travail de la lyre plus
festive avec la fête des voisins
oui mais au travail et l'opération se
déroule le 10 octobre à travers la
france nous en prendrons tout à l'heure
avec nos invités mobilisation contre le
cancer du sang soo à d'octobre parce que
48% des femmes ne participe pas au
dépistage us que chaque année la maladie
entraîne plus de 12000 wc aînés octobre
rose une mobilisation nationale qui
passe notamment par la danse avec vous
l'avez vu plusieurs cours de zumba
organisée afin de lever des fonds
l'image du jour et la lutte contre le
cancer du sein octobre rose
encore ce matin à rambouillet ont été
présentées ces milliers de fleurs abrité
dans le domaine des floraisons rose est
symbole d'un élan de solidarité envers
celles et ceux qui luttent contre le
cancer du sein dès la fin de l'hiver
2012 les plants étaient mis en serre
avant d'être disposés à travers ce site
labellisé jardin remarquable de france
appartenant aujourd'hui au domaine
présidentiel
l'occasion surtout de rappeler que le
cancer du sang se positionne au premier
rang et des décès par cancer chez la
femme 52 % seulement des femmes de plus
de 50 ans se font dépister lors des
campagnes nationales on écoute le
responsable des jardins du domaine de
rambouillet au micro de patrick jacques
de dixmude
pour l'occasion nous avons entrepris de
fleurir le château donc soin dominante
de rose donc tout au long de l'été cette
couleur a été présente dans le domaine
notamment autour du château avec son
bandeau
de pétunias surfinias c'est vraiment une
ceinture de rose à l'enceinte est
également sur les partenaires à
proximité du château et autour du miroir
tout nous avons été société assez
tardivement dans la saison nous avons dû
revoir toutes les plantations qui était
prévu afin de correspondre au projet en
production ça représente à peu près 30
il plante temps sachant qu'en fait il y
en à peu près
les deux tiers qui sont mises en place
on garde toujours un fond de plantes
pour les remplacements éventuels ou ses
diverses ou six ans lors de la la
production octobre rose toujours avec
cet autre opération menée afin de
sensibiliser à l'importance du dépistage
du cancer du sein une zumba cette danse
à la mode a été proposée sur un ton un
peu particulier samedi dernier à
versailles notamment à l'argent récolté
sera reversé à la ligue contre le cancer
et olen thorez patrick jacques de
dixmude
le dress code ce jour-là tout en rose
ces femmes font de la zumba au profit
d'une seule et même cause le cancer du
sein
une femme sur huit est encore touchée en
france comme génie elle s'est engagée
dans la lutte contre le cancer du sein à
travers la zumba jamais vu après le
après les gros matches et un cancer en
j'ai voulu continuer le combat c'est ma
manière à moi de d'aider les autres
femmes qui sont aujourd'hui atteintes
d'un cancer et de leur montrer que voilà
on peut on peut guérir on peut avoir une
vie normale et et la dichotomie
l'objectif de cette journée est aussi de
sensibiliser au dépistage
parce que malheureusement les femmes ne
sont pas assez sensibilisés on pense que
ça arrive à peu près à vers 45 50 ans
parce que le dépistage se fait à partir
de 50 ans mais elle est fan son toucher
de plus en plus jeunes et c'est vraiment
important de se faire dépister le plus
tôt possible
même discours du côté des médecins le
docteur mayer est favorable la
mammographie dès l'âge de 40 ans plus on
se dépister tôt plus on augmente
ouf les chances de guérison et ça c'est
vraiment important
en plus en ayant de moins en moins de
séquelles car plus on dépiste tokyo
diagnostic tôt et moins il y aura de
séquelles des traitements dans la bière
le cancer du sein tue encore plus de dix
mille personnes par an pour ce médecin
les progrès thérapeutiques sont
considérables plus de deux tiers des
femmes en guérissent aujourd'hui la
recherche scientifique tente de mieux
cibler les traitements et pour ça il
faut aussi qu'on ait les moyens
financiers ça c'est un très très gros
débat dans tous les pays et en
particulier en france
cette journée a permis de récolter au
total plus de 3750 euros pour la ligue
contre le cancer du sein chaque année
plus de quarante huit nouveaux cas sont
détectés paris a été élu hier à
cleveland villes hôtes de la 10e édition
des gay games par la fédération
internationale des jeux internationaux
sexuel ce sera en 2018 la capitale
française l'emportent dans le dernier
round face à londres indépendante de
critères sportifs la participation à ces
jeux se fait sur la base d'inscription
rassemble à chaque édition plus de dix
mille concurrents plus que les jeux
olympiques et dernière précision la
compétition est ouverte à tous sans
discrimination pour en parler nous avons
en ligne frédéric barbier bonsoir à vous
vous êtes le directeur de la base de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines la
base de loisirs qui va accueillir
notamment les épreuves de golf c'est
l'un des sites franciliens retenue même
si la plupart et des événements sportifs
se dérouleront sur paris frédéric de
mort dit quelle est votre réaction c'est
un peu une revanche sachant que pour les
jo-2012 la france était opposée à
londres et les dénouements forcément on
le connaît paris avait été écarté bien
sûr bonjour bonjour oui tout à fait
engagé comme vous règlement surpris est
elle vraiment dixièmes à guay puisque
nous référions le vélodrome à l'époque
nous n'aurons pas proximité la date de
ma vie à l'intérieur de la base de la
luire donc fait encore mieux ce sera
effectivement l'épreuve de golf qui a
été retenu sur ce site de la base de
loisirs sur ce site où s'est installé le
le golf il ya une délégation qui est
venu récemment comment s'était passée
samedi tout à fait à une délégation il
ya deux-trois mois dont qui est venu
visiter dans le golfe et les parties des
des lieux repérés on va dire et ils ont
été vraiment surpris d'un moment surpris
par la qualité donc de ce golf de par sa
taille puisque je rappelle que cette
enveloppe de 45 rouge et donc par le
dynamique possible de des gérants
puisque blue green et en portant la vie
gates of a republic et du golfe est tout
aussi imparfait mais incontournable en
france
ces jeux olympiques c'est gay games
plutôt comme c'est comme ça qu'ils
s'appellent ce sera la dixième édition
en général plus de dix mille dix mille
participants il y aura environ 200
participants sur l'épreuve qui concerne
le golf vous attendez des retombées une
visibilité aussi au niveau international
évidemment ce niveau d'interaction
raconte de la nationale internationale
la base de l'avis sera repéré de très
loin et puis comme ça porte des valeurs
de tolérance solidaire on va dire
forcément c'est bien en lien avec la
fiction et la base de la compagnie
merci frédéric bordier d'avoir réagi à
cette obtention par paris et donc par
votre site également de ces gay games
2018 ce sera à paris entre le 4 et le 12
août
et puis à saint quentin en yvelines plus
précisément 8 et 9 août pour le golf
environ 200 participants 50% hommes 50%
femmes et 40 % nord américain selon les
organisateurs des syndicalistes sud de
psa poissy ont entamé une grève de la
faim le 18 septembre cela fait
maintenant vingt jours qu'ils protestent
contre une discrimination syndicale les
précisions cet après midi de clerck en
billets de patrick jacques de dixmude 20
jours de grève de la faim 20 jours que
c'est cet ouvrier syndicaliste sud de
psa poissy campent devant les bureaux de
leur direction leur combat dénoncer
leurs conditions de travail et le
harcèlement moral qu'ils subissent mais
pour le moment leurs revendications sont
restées lettre morte alors leur lutte
continue malgré les alertes des médecins
j'ai un problème cardiaque
et je refuse d'arrêter je préfère crever
ici et ne pas lâcher au nom accolé qui
borde une comptine marche il faut comme
ça ça dernier déférence kokand la
direction jointe par téléphone n'a pas
souhaité s'exprimer
un comité de soutien solidaire
rassemblant associations partis
syndicats a été créée le 3 octobre les
membres se relaie pour soutenir les
grévistes
aujourd'hui c'était au tour d'olivier
besancenot l'espoir qu'on a on verra ce
qui se passe donc le disent après demain
aussi autour de l'accord compétitivité
si si ça peut être aussi un moyen de
toujours faire ressurgir à la surface
quoi voilà pas simplement les accords de
compétitivité mais aussi ce qu'il ya
derrière est ce qui vous arrive aussi
les autres syndicats ne soutiennent pas
leur mouvement né étaient unis le 3
octobre lors d'une mobilisation
nationale contre l'accord compétitivité
samedi les grévistes envie de leur
soutien une marche vers la mairie à 14
heures
et pour être complet sachez que les
salariés rencontrés retour de ce site
nous ont indiqué qu'ils avaient reçu
l'ordre de se taire devant la presse la
direction aurait envoyé également une
lettre aux grévistes leur indiquant
qu'elle soutenait la politique
managériale de ce site de poissy la fête
des voisins a vu le jour en 1999 à paris
dans le 17ème arrondissement à
l'initiative d'une association paris
d'amis aujourd'hui des milliers de
personnes participent et pas uniquement
en france au point d'étendre l'idée au
monde de l'entreprise la fête des
voisins en entreprise première édition
ce sera le 10 octobre nous avons sur ce
plateau albane - bonsoir à vous vous
êtes responsable animation et vie
sociale de l'entreprise medica france
vous allez participer à cet événement
sachets notamment que medica va être en
charge de la future maison de retraite
les pattes de montigny le bretonneux ce
sera en 2016
vous êtes installé aussi dans le
département à maurepas ou encore à
chatou et puis face à vous soit vous
êtes directeur du développement
territorial yvelines d'edf est
responsable d'un psp d'un pont services
particuliers conserver ce particulier du
club face qui est l'un des partenaires
de phase ii trap club fasse partenaires
de ce projet qui était à l'origine
également de l'initiative avec un autre
homme c'est atanase périfan qui est en
ligne avec nous m'ont soit vous vous
êtes le créateur de la fête des voisins
vous avez lancé cette initiative il ya
14 ans au sein de ray
danse pour que les voisins puissent se
connaître pourquoi avoir décidé de
l'étendre au monde de l'entreprise
en fait que pour l'état typhon villa moi
qui ai longtemps et tués soit l'autre
moitié dans l'entreprise et c'est vrai
qu'on se rend compte qu'avec la pression
les rêves il forme avec la
mondialisation avec des 35 heures le gie
modernes de communication n'est pas
facile c'est vrai qu'on est toutes un
petit pression et du poker et moment
presse gratuit et puis se retrouver pour
apprendre à découvrir le collègue du sud
le royaume en face de l'entreprise enfin
et écrite est indispensable mais non
sans compter que le contexte est plutôt
difficile sur un plan économique les
salariés s'inquiètent aussi de pouvoir
regarder ne serait ce que leur travail
déjà c'était le meilleur moment pour
lancer ça pour changer peut-être un
petit peu les idées étaient justement la
raison pour laquelle on l'entend on veut
pas laisser en fait les salariés qui
pression en permanence
il faut retrouver du sens à l'action
collective de l'entreprise sur et qu'en
période de crise chacun craint pour sa
plate mais pour être très clair on
arrivera à prendre tout seul
moi j'étais frappé aujourd'hui par les
gens qui trouvent que les relations
humaines se dégrade dans le travail
c'est impressionnant et les gens
aspirent à changer ça plutôt très tôt
d'une réalité qui est pas toujours et
joyeux mais les gens ont vite changer
les choses et cette fête du travail les
caps prétexte l'occasion qui est
importante et tout va se passer derrière
fait freaker eric valette pour aller
draguer cette entraide composeront
qu'une petite permis avec le bureau
c'est que le début c'est pour commencer
à nouer des liens et qu'ensuite les gens
puissent échanger au quotidien et ce qui
est le plus values aussi de vous
attendez ne serait ce que pour les
dirigeants des entreprises qui vont
participer c'est évident dans la tête
qu'on m'a mené en fait on a interrogé
les pompiers pour savoir et qui tous
qu'il ya un lien entre les cas qui lui
mène dans le travail la relation et les
performances et collègues de
l'entreprise
plus de la moitié aux salariés bien
évidemment la compétition les
performances économiques ne peuvent pas
aller dans le bien être au travail des
sujets qui sont intéressants donc les
dix régions kit intérêt à ce que les
collègues de bureau s'entendent bien et
surtout on rentre ou en fait dimension
humaine
on a perdu un peu partout aujourd'hui la
roulade sur lot avaient compliqué en
bois dans nos comptes entre parents
enfants entre brevets de certains
membres de bureau entre voisins or
mettons un peu loin dans l'entreprise en
matière de voir
le projet de la fête des voisins projet
initial qui aujourd'hui s'exporte dans
36 pays à travers le monde on vous
souhaite bien évidemment le même succès
merci d'avoir été en ligne avec nous que
j'étais à l'origine de l événement nous
allons continuer à en parler de cette
fête des voisins au travail avec nos
deux invités en plateau elle d'un côté
entreprises d'un côté le club fasse
également pour le club fasse d'abord
pour commencer vous êtes d'accord avec
ce qui vient d'être dit c'était le
meilleur moment pour le lancer ce projet
dans un contexte économique difficile
sociale difficile
oui je pense que ce contexte économique
et social qui est difficile doit
favoriser et met en exergue justement
cette relation que les personnes doivent
avoir au travail pour justement être
plus fort pour lutter contre cette
morosité et les problèmes économiques
qui peuvent rencontrer donc j'ai poussé
ma claque face à s'inscrire à participer
le club fasse tout à fait qui est
sensible à tout ce qui va générer du
lien social que ce soit dans
l'entreprise que ce soit dans dans la
vie de tous les jours a voulu s'y
associer parce que c'est tout à fait en
lien avec les différents objectifs qu'il
s'est donnée toujours par rapport à ce
lien social
quel objectif justement pour votre
groupe medica côté entreprises cette
fois-ci vous êtes dit font que les
autres les salariés entre commencent à
échanger qui est plus de liens
traitement nous sommes dans un domaine
du sanitaire et social ce sont des
maisons de retraite et des cliniques
les sièges sociaux participent aussi à
cette opération de fête des voisins au
travail en fait la fête des voisins a
été développé le partenariat il ya cinq
ans par le service animation et vie
sociale du groupe
car déjà lancé ce type de projet avant
même cette fête des voisins
de nombreux événements sont créés sur
nos établissements à longueur d'année et
la fée des voisins ont fait partie avec
la particularité évidemment d'être un
très gros vecteur de lien social d'être
reconnu par l'ensemble des partenaires
locaux nous établissements sont ouverts
justement avec les partenaires et les
intervenants extérieurs sur ceux sur ses
portes ouvertes qui sont plutôt des
portes ouvertes en fait sur les
événements et nous retrouvons à travers
la fête des voisins au travail le même
vecteur mais pour les salariés c'est
vraiment ce qu'il recherchait cette
notion d' échange de convivialité et de
lien social
on va donner la parole à quelques
nous avons rencontré aujourd'hui dans
les rues de saint quentin en yvelines
que pense-t-il de cette idée de la fête
des voisins et puis on en reparle après
en plateau avec les voisins en général j
très peu de contacts donc est voisin du
travail on va dire encore moins et pas
forcément le temps éventuellement
pourquoi pas éventuellement mais c'est
pas ce fait pas partie mais
prioritairement dire si le look plus 4e
oui à faire des voisins de travail oui
vachement bien des treuils d'abord pour
créer un peu de lien avec les copains de
travail
voilà les puits en plus ça permet aussi
de recruter pour syndicats c'est une
bonne idée c'est original donc pourquoi
pas la mettre en place
je pense que dans l'esprit du travail en
plus si on peut en plus avoir du plaisir
avec les collègues c'est toujours mieux
c'est une très bonne idée bas à un peu
plus de convivialité c'est vrai que je
pense que ça se perd en entreprise
effectivement donc je suis pour parce
qu'en fait déjà déjà on a du mal à se
connaître dans nos bâtiments à nous ça
serait bien aussi de connaître un petit
peu aussi les autres on a tout
simplement des voisins travail en open
space j'en ai tout le temps donc c'est
la fête tous les jours c'est la fête
tous les jours effectivement cette fête
des voisins au travail qui s'adresse
aussi bien aux collègues que aux
salariés des entreprises qui seraient
voisine c'est le but créer du lien c'est
justement ce sera le cas justement dans
vos dans vos centres pour les laissant
dirigé par des visions participent à
l'opération et compris les intervenants
extérieurs les partenaires sociétés que
nous avons au niveau territorial et les
prestataires que nous retrouvons par
exemple les kinés les médecins qui sont
en lien avec l'établissement et les
ambulanciers sont bien sûr invités
conviés à cet événement c'est un petit
peu faire un type de management
différent et les résultats sont plutôt
positifs parce que vous avez déjà mené
ce type de dispositif ait eu un
baromètre aussi du moral de vos salariés
qui a été fait par un par l'entreprise
commandé auprès de l'institut csa 93% de
vos salariés qui aime travailler chez
vous ils sont environ 12000 vous avez
enduré en 2000 collaborateurs et vous
faites régulièrement des sondages pour
savoir si
présente de faisons alors comment vous
expliquer ces résultats
il ya 75 % de participation peu près à
ce sondage à chaque fois il faut croire
que la convivialité il fait peut-être
bon vie chez melick à 72,2 politique
vous avez souhaité complètement nous
sommes très attachés au bien-être des
salariés évidemment et nous avons une
réflexion permanente sur aussi la
responsabilité sociale de l'entreprise
comme le club fasse vous constatez ça
c'est plutôt bonne politique menée à
s'être al'écoute comme ça des salariés
une approche différente de l'entreprise
aussi je pense que c'est indispensable
1 aujourd'hui club face et 4500
entreprises et on espère sur la journée
de jeudi que 2000 entreprises vont
participer à cette manifestation et que
ça va concerner environ cent mille
personnes
mais c'est bien mettre en exergue la
relation sur une action sur une journée
comme ça après faut aussi être capable
de pouvoir la prolonger mais c'est vrai
que dans un monde économique qui est
difficile je pense que les bonnes
relations au travail vont permettre une
très bonne efficacité et à mes yeux ça
d'écart plus les tout le monde y trouve
son compte
des images de la fête des voisins alors
ça c'est pour la fête des voisins entre
particuliers côté entreprises comment
prolonger c'est ce qu'on me disait il
faut prolonger l'opération
ensuite comment ça va s'entretenir au
quotidien vous allez y veiller ou
organiser même d'autres choses en dehors
de ce cadre
alors c'est vrai c'est vrai que dans un
premier temps il va y avoir un lien qui
va se faire sur des choses très simples
à la machine à café ou quelqu'un qui va
qui va réunir des collègues autour
autour d'une bouteille ou d'un verre et
puis il part des échanges c'est vrai que
derrière il faut soit que l'entreprise
crée un environnement pour continuer à
relier on soit parfois ce sont les
individus eux mêmes qui vont prolonger
tout ça mais c'est vrai que c'est il
faut un certain investissement pour que
ça puisse avoir un impact sur la durée
alors cette journée du 10 octobre cette
fête des voisins au travail comment ça
va se dérouler dans vos établissements
des événements soit l'établissement ça
va être le matin au petit déjeuner ça
peut être autour d'un buffet ça peut
être l'après midi autour d'un goûter
autour de défi sportif nous avons
vraiment énormément de moments
l'essentiel c'est que ce soit un moment
que ce soit simple ou de plus grande
envergure conviviale que chacun des
établissements est libre un petit peu
dans l'organisation de sa journée
l'essentiel c'est la boisson végétale
12h et puis les mots des épi les
rencontres évidemment entre entre
chacune collaborateurs les braults delà
de ça vous allez poursuivre justement
continuer à organiser ce type de rendez
vous et tout à l'heure nous avons
régulièrement des échanges nous sommes
dans un domaine où la convivialité
devient social et est indissociable de
nos métiers au quotidien donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose à poursuivre avec
la différence que la fête des voisins au
travail ça permet vraiment d'avoir une
journée qui marque ces journées pour les
collaborateurs
donc je pense que c'est important qu'ils
vous pensez pas que les collaborateurs
justement vont se dire entre la fête des
voisins entre la fête des voisins au
travail on a aussi du travail à faire je
suis pas du tout comme ça que j'ai été
accueilli et c'est plutôt bien ça veut
dire que c'est vraiment quelque chose de
moteur qui est bien compris avec eux
avec du sens très bien merci beaucoup à
vous merci à vous deux vous êtes déjà
partants pour l'année prochaine
question et vous allez la faire cette
fête des voisins au travail même si bien
sûr mais pas très bien vous viendrez
vous dire comment ça s'est passé merci à
tous les deux être vrai avoir répondu à
notre invitation road cette date de la
fête des voisins au travail ce sera le
10 octobre et puis y'a un site internet
aussi si vous souhaitez initier le
mouvement dans votre entreprise vous y
trouverez des détails pratiques des
entreprises qui étaient aussi à
l'honneur aujourd'hui mardi
montigny le bretonneux une partie
d'entre elles du moins qui participé à
la semaine du handicap lancé voici dix
ans par la municipalité
mardi midi se tenait la cinquième
édition de la course inter entreprises
l'objectif de cette réunion récolter des
fonds pour une association d'enfants
handicapés le reportage d'olivier
maniscalco et d'élodie moines
vêtu d'un tee shirt rouge et sourire aux
lèvres les enfants handicapés de l'iem
des mesnuls sont déjà à l'échauffement
dans quelques instants ils prendront le
départ de la 5e course inter entreprises
de montigny ça fait la troisième année
une quatrième année consécutive
on participe à ses coups et je trouve ça
bien pour les jeunes parce que courir on
s'occupe que de soi et on va le plus
loin possible plus vite possible au
sénat bien participer matthieu certains
c'est les premiers mais pas tous plus
deuxième pour que je perde dans les rues
organisé par l'association spécial
olympics france
le principe de cette course est simple
les entreprises inscrivent leurs équipes
de quatre coureurs qui s'élancent pour
10 km sous forme de relais
l'inscription coûte 800 euros par équipe
et les fonds récoltés sont reversés aux
enfants handicapés
j'ai déjà fait un semi marathon pour les
handicapés de charte donc voilà c'est
quelque chose que j'apprécie c'est très
convivial en plus on se retrouve avec
plusieurs entreprises
et voilà donc c'est la fête donc
profitons-en
les relayeurs des buts de la place
etienne marcel pour un effort de deux
kilomètres et demi croisant
régulièrement les enfants pour qu'ils
courent
chacun fait de son mieux même si le
sport n'est pas forcément une sinécure
pour certains c'est pour la bonne cause
donc là on a tout donné
au final enfin bon temps en plus on les
a vus devant nous
soixante dix sept équipes pour 310
coureurs ont participé à la course cette
année 43 1200 euros ont pu être récoltés
ces 8000 euros de mieux que l'année
dernière
solidarité avec les esat ces
établissements et services d'aidé par le
travail le site de l'as marsa 20 attrape
accueille maintenant une blanchisserie
ce sont douze nouveaux emplois qui ont
été créés lors de l'inauguration le
ministre socialiste benoît hamon étaient
présents catherine de la tow patrick
jacques de dixmude une blanchisserie
agrandi 12 postes nouveaux ainsi créa
les aides de trappes un centre
d'adaptation pour les personnes en
situation de handicap
aujourd'hui une tonne de vêtements et
traités par semaine encore plus fan qui
arrive là bas
le cru que ce soir de parlant il a posé
pour chaque union pour l'occasion
l'inauguration s'est déroulée en
présence de benoît hamon ministre de
l'économie sociale et solidaire une
cerise sur le gâteau pour les directeurs
nous sommes très très heureux de voir
les esat entrer dans l'orbité dont le
giro de l'économie sociale et solidaire
je crois que ça se passe dans la joie et
la bonne humeur et c'est le reflet
vraiment deux quotidiens de les actes de
la mafia
une certaine fierté de rencontrer un
ministre alors du coup nous avons
demandé aux salariés de les attaques
s'ils avaient une question à poser à
benoît mme la question c'est le salaire
c'est si on peut être fait un peu plus
est bon si on est en état de salaires
bruts et des as et 160 565 c'est un vrai
sujet parce que on veut tous pouvoir
tirer avantage de son travail est
rémunéré correctement ça repose sur la
négociation dans l'entreprise c'est du
privé à part le smic l'état de fixer ou
le salaire des fonctionnaires
les tags ne fixe aucun salaire je trouve
ça aujourd'hui 5 dans un établissement
comme celui là comme dans beaucoup
d'autres entreprises on pose la question
du salaire donc j'espère à court terme
j'espère à court terme mais c'est vrai
que la priorité pour nous pour l'état
aussi bien pour le travail
des travailleurs handicapés que pour le
travail en milieu ordinaire de travail
en général notre priorité c'est l'emploi
puis il ya de l'emploi plus les gens
consomment plus c'est bon pour
l'économie et donc plus on pourra
augmenter les salaires derrière le
ministre est aussi venu avec d'autres
pistes de travail
benoît hamon aimerait défendre l'idée
que les esat est les entreprises
adaptées ainsi que les entreprises
d'insertion puissent avoir accès à des
marchés réservés pour des commandes
publiques
réponse en novembre lors de l'examen
d'un projet de loi présenté au sénat
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
retrouve demain en direct dès 18h pour
un nouveau point complet sur
l'information locale n'oubliez pas que
vous pouvez retrouver nos précédentes
éditions et tous les reportages sur
notre site internet via les un replay et
puis à vos commentaires sur les réseaux
sociaux excellente soirée à demain